This video is made possible by Dash Lane.
Dashlane is a one stop shop digital identity protections or who go beyond just
being an amazing password manager and provide identity protection,
monitoring the restoration and more.
Visit [inaudible] dot com forward slash buyer graphics and apply the promocode
biographics for a 10% discount.
Yeah,
the beds are getting favors.
The Iraq war logs US history.
It's full of infamous leaks that blew the government wide open,
but there's one set of leaks that stands head and shoulders above the others.
In 2013 a contractor with the national security agency or NSA quietly handed a
cache of documents to the Guardian.
These details how the NSA had been hoovering up information on millions of
Americans while lying to Congress.
It was the single most explosive story of the post nine 11 era and the man
behind it all.
Well,
that was Edward Snowden,
a young computer whiz from North Carolina.
Snowden is today infamous.
Currently.
He's holed up in assign them in Russia.
He's both loved and loathed by millions to some,
he's a fearless whistle blower who sacrificed everything to do what was right to
others.
He's the 21st century version of a cold war to factor,
but the truth,
it's more complex than either of those portrayals.
Snowden's life is one of contradictions of surprises and enough shades of gray
to fill a million el James novels.
Today we investigate the man behind the most notorious leak in American history.
Cool.
If you know the name Elizabeth City,
North Carolina,
it's likely because of the coast guard base by some measures the busiest in the
United States.
The base dominates the lives of local residents,
the Snowdens,
they were no exception.
When Edward Joseph Snowden was born on June the 21st in 1983 it was into a
family with deep military connections.
Youngest Snowden's maternal grandfather,
Edward J.
Barrett was a rear admiral and his father Lani also worked in the coast guard
for Snowden lemons or childhood in stills with deep respect for the services,
but it was also a childhood marked by something more tragic.
The slow breakdown of his parents.
His marriage,
lowly ans Elizabeth Snowden,
known to our friends as Wendy were high school sweethearts,
married young.
Although Wendy suffered from epilepsy.
Yep.
Wasn't debilitating.
She managed to get a job as a Maryland district court.
Clark moving the family north in 1992 but if the Snowdens were expecting their
new lives in Maryland to be easy,
all they were mistaken as Wendy and lawns,
marriage drifted young.
Snowden was stumbling into a crisis at high school despite being clearly
intelligent.
The teenage boy,
he didn't really excel at anything.
What do you missed?
Four months study after capturing glandular fever in 1998 it knocked him back to
a place that he couldn't recover from.
He flunked out of high school,
perhaps desperate to sell something from this debacle.
Snowden enrolls in computer classes and our and Dell community college,
but his prospects,
they were pretty low message board posts left around this time,
tinge with cheerful desperation about being unemployed.
The family stumbled on for another couple of years,
but by 2001 the writing was on the wall.
When do you get along?
Splits and Wendy took off Ellicott city.
Now Baltimore one year later,
19 year olds,
Snowden.
He followed her.
At this stage,
Edward Snowden was about as far from a potential biographics subjects is you're
likely to get his only achievement was being webmaster of an anime message
board.
Yep.
Even now,
there were two clues as to his future near to righty.
The first was his and comparable tech skills.
After enrolling,
it's an RN.
Snowden had discovered this.
He had not just an aptitude for computers,
but of genius.
Ellicott city is home to somewhere that's going to become very important to us
story.
It's home to the NSA's headquarters.
Unfortunately,
they real life isn't as narratively pleasing as fiction and we'll need to take a
quick detour in order to get that.
On march the 20th 2003 the US invaded Iraq,
although the main fighting was over by the end of May,
a call for new recruits went out and nationwide.
This cool struck a chord with the unemployed Snowden.
Maybe it was his family's coast guard backgrounds,
but for whatever reason,
Snowden felt compelled to join up in May,
2004 he reported for duty at Fort Benning,
Georgia.
His training,
it didn't last long.
Snowden later claims that he broke both legs,
but the army claimed he flunked out with Shin splints.
Either way.
The result was the same.
After barely a month snooted was discharged.
He returned to merrylands again and unemployed failure.
Finally,
in 2005 Snowden got a security guard job at Maryland Center for Advanced Study
of language and it was really here that our story could have ended except for
one little fact.
That center,
it was backed by the NSA and the NSA would desperate to recruit computer geeks
off of the Soviet Union.
Fell all the way back in 1991 America's intelligence agencies.
They went through an era of downsizing and shedding of staff.
That all changed on September the 11th 2001 faced with the new threat of
terrorism.
The agencies would desperate to make up for lost time.
They were all so desperate to catch up with evolving tech way into the two
thousands the senior staff was so technologically illiterate that it would be a
challenge for them to distinguish the difference between a laptop and a sandwich
and with that it was clearly time to start hiring our best tech guys and one of
the best just happened to be working as an NSA security guard.
Within months Snowden had switched his security job for it.
He must have made an impression because not two years after flunking out of
basic military training in mid 2006 young Snowden and got a job offer from the
CIA saying yes to that offer would turn out to be a key decision in his life.
The young it genius was whisked away to Geneva in Switzerland in 2007 while this
drug was a mixture of cool and not so cool from maintaining network security to
just fixing the ACC on the money it paid was certainly joke.
As a CIA technician,
Snowden was able to live every boy's James Bond fantasies.
He bought a brand new BMW,
befriended an Estonian Rockstar,
played the stock market boasting that had lost $20,000 in a single month.
He also traveled extensively your washing up in Rome,
Bosnia,
and in London.
Not that his opinions of these places were always PC of London's vibrant Muslim
community.
He wrote,
they were terrifying.
I didn't want to get out of the car yet.
Even in this dream job,
disillusionment could create them.
In 2008 Snowden supposedly witnessed the CIA arranging for a banker to be caught
drunk driving and then offering to suppress the charge and return for
cooperation.
The Swiss authorities.
They've denied this ever happened.
It's still the anguish that Snowden felt working for the CIA.
It was certainly the real he would like to claim.
Much of what I saw in Geneva really disillusioned me about how my government
functions.
I realized that I was a part of something that was doing far more harm than
good.
Not that he seems like a potential whistleblower just yet.
When the New York Times published a leaked Pentagon plans,
you attack Iran in 2009 Snowden raged online.
There's anyone who leaked such information to the press should be shot in the
balls still.
There was no doubt that Snowden was struggling with something in Geneva and it
was making him angry.
In February of 2009 he abruptly resigned from the CIA.
Later sources in the agency said that had been on the verge of being fired for
trying to hack into their database back in the United States.
The young computer whiz he underwent to change his message board posts the game
full of angry rants against government programs like social welfare ans
invective against Obama's new administration in a world full of angry young men.
It seemed Edward Snowden was simply another voice screaming into the void,
but it was one crucial difference here.
Snowden was still useful within a couple of months of leaving the CIA,
Snowden had a new job this time as a contractor for Dell working on NSA
projects.
The first was working on anti cyber spying software in Tokyo for a lifelong
anime fan and moving to Japan should have been a dream come true,
but instead at punched Snowden into a moral nightmare.
On April the fifth 2010 wiki leaks is Julian Assange previewed a leaked military
video at a national press club events known as collateral murder.
It showed the u s military pilots is gunning down to writers,
journalists,
mistaken for terrorists in Baghdad.
In 2007 the video was the first major scoop and the history of Wiki leaks.
It was also the beginning of the biggest intelligence leak in history throughout
the rest of the year.
Wiki leaks,
the Guardian,
The New York Times and Daesh Beagle published the Afghan war logs,
the Iraq war logs,
and finally a trove of us diplomatic cables that were leaks supplied to
wikileaks by intelligence analyst Chelsea Manning.
The classified files turn the world's opinion of the United States upside down,
but not Edward Snowden's over in Japan.
The young it professional,
it become increasingly disturbed.
The work the NSA was up two on February the 18th 2010 he posted it on a message
board.
It really concerns me how little this sort of corporate behavior bothers those
outside of technology circles.
Society really seems to have developed an unquestioning obedience towards spooky
types.
It wasn't until Manning's leaks shook the media that Snowden seems to have
decided to reveal the NSA's secrets.
In 2011 Dell trends heading back to Maryland from Japan on the outside.
This was perfect for Snowden.
He moved in with his younger girlfriends.
The free spirited Lindsay mills insights noted had made a decision.
It was while back in Maryland that he started downloading the documents that he
would soon release to the entire world.
In 2012 a Snowden contacted the tor project and online community dedicated to
providing everyone with the tools needed to encrypt their internet activity.
While this seems innocuous enough,
tool was deeply connected with wikileaks.
Many have suggested that Snowden made contact with tor as a way of getting to a
sauna.
If that was the plan,
though,
it's soon run into trouble with a capital t.
On June the 19th 2012 the wikileaks founder fled to the Ecuadorian embassy in
London to avoid an arrest on a rape charge.
The subsequent media Sakkas may have made snoot and rethink.
Wikileaks is the place to publish his revelations by now Snowden and mills.
They were in Hawaii where Snowden had to work on the is regional crypto logical
center.
At this point,
he was actively looking for opportunities to steal documents,
but he may have also been looking for something else.
Validation for his genius that some of Snowden,
the hacks in the answers for an NSA job promotion test and subsequently aced it
when he was offered a new position.
He got angry that it wasn't high enough up and he rejected it.
Vanessa is deputy director would later tell reporters that he considers this the
moment when Snowden turned on the agency,
whatever the truth,
it wasn't only at work that people were noticing the change and Snowden in July,
2012 Lindsay mills blogs at the couple's relationship in Hawaii.
He was under stress by October.
She was writing about heavy conversations and stress paralysis,
whatever was preying on Snowden's mind.
It was certainly tormenting them.
Both that Thanksgiving bills returned to the US mainland to see our family for
an extended break.
While he was away.
Snowden finally set the wheels of his plan in motion on December the first 2012
guardian columnist and vocal wikileaks defender Glenn Greenwald gots a rather
unusual email.
This email suggested that he set up a PGP encryption software on his laptop.
Like anyone getting such a paranoid email.
Greenwald's ignored it.
Assuming the sender was a crank.
Let's all did Greenwald know that this was his first contact with a man who
would soon me cause Korea
a month off to being frozen out by Greenwald's Snowden.
Try it again this time he contacted the journalist's friends,
documentary maker,
Laura Poitras applied truss was deeply connected to the tor project that we
mentioned earlier.
When she first heard from Snowden,
she assumed that he was trying to in trapper,
but when a contact is at all,
it gives nude in the green light.
She again to listen using a fake name.
Snowden told portraits that he was a high ranking intelligence officer.
This was a total lie,
but the next part it wasn't.
He's holds a that he could get ahold of files that would paint the u s in a very
bad light if portraits wanted to see them.
All she had to do was get green mold on board than February.
Snowden changed jobs again while still working at the NSA's Hawaii sends her,
he took a pay cards to move from contracting with Dell to Booz Allen Hamilton.
His new role was a Sysadmin,
a row with two unbelievable bonuses for the potential Leeka.
One,
it made snow to and one of the only people at the NSA with a legitimate reason
to carry it normally forbid and thumb drives,
and two,
it gave them access to almost the entire system is still some to this day,
a skeptical this even assist admin could have access to so many confidential
areas without help.
It's thought Snowden may have stolen 14 people's login credentials to maximize
his reach.
Pros,
node and sources say that he used to CIS admin title to trick people into
handing them over.
Andy's nerd and sources say that he may have received help from Russian
intelligence back in the real world.
Parks.
Forests was desperately trying to convince greenwells that has sauce was on the
level that March,
they tentatively agreed to meet Snowden face to face,
yet the trio,
they missed the first chance.
That very month.
On march the 30th Snowden flew back to the u s maintenance,
but rather than go to meet the journalists see went to see his father on April
the fourth 2013 Lani and Edward,
they had dinner only.
He said that his son seemed preoccupied,
that something was weighing him down when they finished eating.
The two men hugged.
I love you that said,
Snowden.
I love you too son.
Nadia replied back in Hawaii,
the disconnect between Snowden's private and public lives,
it was growing at the same time he had mills moved into a new house.
Glenn Greenwald's was receiving two thumb drives with instructions on how to
encrypt as communications,
not the Greenwald was the only journalist.
Snowden was courting Barton Gellman.
If the Washington post was also in contact with Snowden in May of 2013 and was
even given the first major cash if NSA files,
but Gelman wants it too much time for facts,
checking angry at the delay.
Snowden simply cut him off between a secret chats with Greenwald,
Gelman and portraits.
Snowden was laying the groundwork for his escape.
He told his employers that he was suffering from epilepsy just like his mother
and he needed some time off on May the 17th mills left for sailing vacation with
friends with remarkable understatements Snowden and told her that he might not
be around when she got back three days later,
the 29 year old travel to Honolulu airport and got on a flight to Hong Kong.
He had with him for laptops and a stack of thumb drives carrying an estimated
1.7 million top secret documents.
About a week later,
Greenwald got a message over his newly installed encrypted system asking him to
come to Hong Kong.
Not unreasonably.
Greenwald's asked why in response Snowden's send him a welcome package as
Greenwald I in the files,
his eyes went wild here and black and white was solid proof that the NSA had
knowing me,
lied to Congress about the extent of it's covert surveillance programs and this
it was just taster.
The main course would be waiting for him in Hong Kong provided that he would
come three days later on June the first 2013 Greenwald was on a plane had if
Asia along with him.
Well Laura Poitras and veteran guardian reporter who in McCaskill the story of
the century have just begun.
Now before we get into that story of the century,
let me tell you a bit about Dash Lane Daschle and one of the sponsors you allow
us to make this longer form content.
Now this video talks a lot about data security,
but this isn't just something that nations have to be aware of.
You too as well.
Dash Shlain is a one stop shop digital identity protections.
That includes a VPN for all of your devices so you can use public internet
safely and anonymously.
They also do something called dark web monitoring,
which basically means they monitor the underbelly of the web for people selling
your data and then alerts you if this is happening further.
If a service you have signed up for Equifax or Sony for example,
stuff is a breach nationally and tell you right away and they'll alert you to
other services which share that username and password so you can change that
information before hackers get access to those other sites.
Plus Dash Lane does what it's always done.
It stores your passwords,
it keeps you personal,
data's secure,
it fills all of those annoying boxes for payment info in passwords all for you.
A lot of dash lane is free,
but there are some premium upgrades you can buy if you want to get more from the
service to see if those arrived for gear.
You could take a 30 day free trial and after that to get a 10% discount code
using our code biographics at [inaudible] dot com forward slash biographics link
also below.
And let's get back to the story of the century,
shall we
mostly.
So when the dust had settled,
Glenn Greenwald would write that he was expecting to meet a veteran of the
intelligence services and the hyper crowded city.
The expected of someone middle aged grizzles and maybe some gray have very much
looking like a secret operative.
In Snowden,
though he got the exact opposite.
Prior to leaving,
the reporters are arranged to meet Snowden in the lobby of the Mirror hotel and
imposing glass edifice and Trendy Kowloon.
It's no Dylan and supplied them with code words and said that he would be
carrying a Rubik's cube the first day green mold and poetry is weighted only for
Snowden to not show.
The second day they waited again,
giving the on his pills for the heavyset ex military man carrying a Rubik's
cube.
When they saw skinny,
delicate Edward Snowden,
Greenwald later said that his heart sank still.
They started the script Greenwald sauntered up to the young man and asked,
what time does the restaurant open at noon came the reply,
but don't go there.
The food sucks for a moment.
The two stood there awkwardly.
Then Snowden muttered,
follow me and add them to this room.
Right up until Snowden began talking,
Greenwald was convinced that the whole thing was just a waste of time,
but as they settled into the anonymous room and Snowden began do spin his tail,
the doubt,
the melted away.
What was left was a feeling of sheer terror as poetry films.
Snowden told Greenwald how the NSA could hack any phone the world and turn it
into a microphone that spied on its owner.
He explained that nearly every social media platform had been compromised by the
u s government and its allies in prison,
Israel and elsewhere.
We're also hoovering up metadata on every citizen and this gave them an accurate
picture of your entire life.
Your loves,
your dreams,
your frustrations,
your desires,
even the type of sleazy movies you like to watch.
All of this was available for them to access privacy.
It's just an illusion.
At some points,
Greenwald invited when McCaskill up to meet Snowden as the most experienced
report to McCaskill would be able to sniff out if Snyder was faking it.
He even had a special code to use with the Guardian offices.
If Snowden was hoaxer,
hitech stays single sentence to the u s editor of the Guinness is bad.
No long after the text arrived at the Pampers officer's saying the Guinness is
good green walls ans McCaskill's fest story.
It went live at 7:00 PM on June the sixth 2013 did you telling how phone company
Verizon had allowed the NSA to collect data on millions of Americans.
It was an absolute bombshell.
Barely 24 hours later.
It was followed by Bart Gilman's,
delayed Washington Post story on the NSA's prison system and NSA headquarters.
The stories triggered a meltdown.
They knew they had a mole,
but they didn't know it was on June the eighth the agency use digital footprints
do identify snowed and as the likely leaker,
and this was the moment when the young hackers,
normal life,
it ended to this day,
the extent of Snowden's theft,
it remains unknown.
The NSA estimates 1.7 million documents went missing,
of which only 1% have been released,
something the rest found their weight to the Kremlin.
Others believe Snowden wasn't lying when he said,
you're talking to a copies to Russia like so much in this town of lies and
shadows.
The truth to this air remains hidden,
but on that day in 2013 the NSA,
they feared the worst.
At 3:00 PM on June the ninth Snowden consented to the Guardian uploading a video
in which she confessed to being the source of the leaks.
He claims had outed himself to control the narrative,
to stop the NSA spinning a false or counter story.
Former NSA analysts,
though they've said it's because he's an EGOMANIAC.
Before an hour was out,
the video was playing all over the world.
By the time morning dawns on June the 10th they widely Twitter user had
identified the Mirror hotel from its lamps.
As journalists converged on the hotel's,
Snowden commonly dressed and slipped out into the sprawling concrete jungle of
Hong Kong.
It was a sweltering day.
Yeah,
thick with humidity and Edward Snowden.
He was now the most wanted man alive.
The ripples that slowly spread out from the Snowden's vanishing acts.
They were many effecting people half the planet away in Hawaiian.
Lindsay Mills panics and pulls her own disappearing acts vanishing to America's
west coast in Iceland.
I remember that Snowden was,
is headed there,
caused mass proce noted protests on the streets since a diplomatic incident with
the u s in the Ecuadorian Embassy in London.
Julian Assange leapt on the phone and demanded wikileaks.
Get a representative to Hong Kong and Co.
Op The story.
This is how many you go.
Young Brits named Sarah Harrison wound up flying to the city with a mission to
track down the NSA,
Nika and Hong Kong itself.
A gang of human rights lawyers led by Canadian Robert Tebeau set up a safe house
system,
giving Snowden places to stay in the city,
slums as generalists and intelligence operatives combs the CD streets and waded
through pools of Neon Snowden disappeared into the homes of Hong Kong's
forgotten and neglected today.
Those that helped him.
All asylum seekers are known as the Snowden refugees.
Even without as made player though the story,
it's still rumbled.
On on June the 14th for the US Justice Department charge,
the missing contracted with espionage and arrest warrant was sent to the Hong
Kong authorities.
One week later,
Robert Tebow made contact with Hong Kong officials asking if they would extra
diapers.
Clients by now wikied at Sarah Harrison had successfully found Snowden when Hong
Kong's people declined to answer.
She suggested that he had for asylum in Ecuador.
The nes was closing it in an interview with Glenn Greenwald,
CNN.
Helpfully it reveals that Snowden Western in Hong Kong on June the 20 seconds us
authorities counseled his passport and with that snow didn't have to go on the
run.
The next day,
Snowden and Harrison boarded a flight to Moscow,
supposedly intending to catch a flight to Havana and then another to Ecuador.
Hong Kong's possible control fail to detain either of them.
When asked why,
they would later say that the u s had follows an international arrest warrants
for Edward James Snowden,
Edward Joseph Snowden.
That's evening June the 23rd 2013 Snowden and Harrison touchdown Moscow's
international airport.
To a media succuss,
someone likely and official and Hong Kong has leaks to the outline as
destination to the press under international pressure.
Russian officials refuse to let.
Snowden bought his flight to Havana at the time that to me,
a Putin claims Snowden's arrival in Moscow was an unwanted Christmas gift.
However,
the Wall Street Journal has since claimed that Snowden was in contact with the
Kremlin and the last desperate days before his flight from Hong Kong.
Regardless,
it was here that Snowden's time as James Bond.
The finally ended stock in the International Transit Lounge of the apple for a
month.
His entire life was in limbo even as the Guardian and Washington Post kept
publishing stories based on his material so that would have been self was
regulated to a bit posh,
a strange ghost hanging around and apple at lounge on the 1st of August,
2013 over a month after he touched down Edward Snowden was allowed to leave the
app or with Harrison,
the whistleblower was granted.
Temporary refugee state has in Russia and he's been there ever since.
But don't worry,
this video is not going to end with Snowden slinking out of Moscow airport,
one warm day in 2013 this still one more act to get through.
Okay.
The legacy of Edward Snowden is a story in its own right,
not least in how different countries treat us.
The revelations in the UK agents from Gchq rated the Guardian's offices and
smashed up their hard drives,
but long after parliament passed new laws actually expanding that agencies
powers in the U S Obama led the charge personally criticizing Snowden,
but nonetheless setting up an independent panel examining us surveillance
practices.
In December of 2013 the panel recommended that a bulk collection of data be
suspended as unconstitutional.
Today,
the NSA operates under close congressional oversight.
So what else has happened?
Well,
the Snowden revelations arguably led to the use extremely strict Gdpr data
protection laws just as they led to Russia,
China,
and others passing data sovereignty laws,
meaning any data collected on their citizens must be physically stored on their
servers in their territory.
As for Greenwald and Co.
Well,
they wound up winning the 2014 Pulitzer Prize on the darker side.
US intelligence agencies have said the damage done by the leaks was irreparable
trust.
It was lost between nations and terrorists were given an intimate knowledge of
NSA operations as how the man behind this chaos.
Well,
it's been a mixed bag.
On October the ninth 2013 Edward Snowden was spotted in Moscow for the first
time since leaving the airport not long after his father bond flew out to visit
quite what the two talks about.
Their day remains a mystery.
In March of 2014 snood and made his first online speaking appearance at Texas is
south by southwest festival.
Today.
Such engagements are his main source of income,
nursing him an estimated $200,000 a year.
What the life is all roses and honey for the man trapped in Moscow in 2018 need
desponded.
Snowden told reporters that Russia was a corrupt society and he no longer felt
safe that as for the United States,
Washington still considers the whistle blower I wanted man.
So at the end of all that excitement,
what can we really say about Edward Snowden?
Was he a hero or was he a traitor?
You're answer.
Well,
who really knows?
We can't really answer the question.
Despite what you hear on line,
it's likely that no one really knows the answer except for Edward Snowden
himself.
The story of Edward Snowden,
it's not over yet.
It could ends with an unexpected presidential pardon a week from now.
It could end in 60 years when Snowden dies alone in an anonymous Moscow
apartment.
Still I wanted man or it could end and a billion other ways.
All we know for sure is that the final chapter in the life of Edward Snowden is
still to be written,
but it's place in history.
Well,
that's already a shirt,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did give us a thumbs up below,
do not forget to subscribe brand new videos just like this multiple times a
week.
So hit that subscribe button and the bell if you wants you to say,
you know,
you actually find out about these videos.
Also support our spikes supporting our sponsor dash lane.
Please find a link to them below and as always,
thank you for watching.